join a joy that she is gonna be helping
us out when I was her age I came and
worked with my father in this room
special assistant to the governor for $1
a year my father never gave me the
dollar a year I will give you the dollar
a year but it's she's she's not working
for obvious reasons and she's here to
help and that's a joy to me Melissa de
Rosa who everybody knows she worked for
President Obama she was chief of staff
to the Attorney General she's been
working with me for seven years she's
current secretary to the governor Larry
Schwartz former deputy County Executive
Suffolk former deputy County Executive
Westchester former secretary to the
Governor Paterson then former secretary
to the governor under Governor Cuomo
2011 to 2015 and Bill Malraux a
financial expert secretary to the
governor 2015 to 2017 the reason I
wanted you to meet these people some
ways it's like putting the band back
together but it's also the most
competent group of government
professionals that you could put
together to address this difficult time
I've worked with these people for 30
years we've gone through all sorts of
different situations together we did
superstorm sandy together the Ebola
virus together we've had problems with
the federal government we built airports
roads bridges so they are just the best
team that you could have working on
behalf of the state of New York and I
thank them all very much for their help
and their assistance and their
volunteerism because most of them are
not getting paid you're getting $1 the
increase in the number of cases
continues and that is what we're
watching every day they see it as an
upward
trajectory I see it as a wave that will
break at one point and the question is
what is the point of the break and if
when the wave breaks does it crash over
the healthcare system right that's what
we've been talking about so two tracks
simultaneously you have to reduce the
spread of the rate of the virus the rate
of spread of the virus you're not really
going to control the spread but you can
reduce the rate of the spread so you can
handle it in your hospital system that's
what every state is doing that's what
this is all about how do you reduce the
rate of spread reduce the density do
more testing isolate the people who test
positive second track increase Hospital
capacity as quickly as you can so that
at the apex of the wave you have the
hospital capacity for the people who
will need the husk hospital capacity
which are the vulnerable people that we
have been talking about reducing the
spread density control we've taken every
action that government can take close
gyms theaters other high-density
businesses non-essential employees
social distancing Mathilda's law
remember this is about protecting
vulnerable people older people senior
citizens compromised immune underlying
illness those are the people who are
vulnerable here that's the focus of all
of this the greatest densest density
control issue right now is in New York
City
I saw the issue myself I told New York
City I want a plan
yesterday I said I want a plan on how
they're going to control and reduce the
density I want the plan today I want the
state to be able to approve the plan it
has to focus on young people and the
gathering of young people I've said it
before you can get it the numbers show
you can get it if you're a young person
and you can transmit it and you're it's
reckless and it's violative of your
civic spirit and duty as a citizen as
far as I'm concerned if New York City
needs legislation to enact their plan
once we approve it
I would ask New York City to pass that
legislation quickly if they have a
problem passing legislation they should
let me know also in reducing the spread
increase your in the test increase the
testing capacity when you identify
somebody positive isolate that person
what we've done on testing is important
March 13th is when the state got the
authority to start testing right up
until then the federal government was
controlling all the testing and it was
going through that bottleneck of a
federal government I don't mean that in
a pejorative way but it had to go
through the FDA the CDC I said
decentralize that task let the states do
it
March 13th the FDA allowed the state to
start testing in ten days we have gone
from testing 1,000 people per day to
16,000 people per day well how much is
that that's more than any other state in
the United States is testing that's more
per capita than South Korea which was
the gold standard of testing they were
doing 20,000 per day on a much larger
population about double the population
of New York so we're doing 16,000 which
compared to China South Korea per capita
is even higher so in short we're doing
more testing than anyone two points off
that kudos to the team that put that
testing in place and the nurses and the
doctors god bless them for being out
there every day in doing it but also our
numbers will be higher on positives
because we're doing more tests we have
multiple locations working now and we'll
be increasing those locations second
track increased Hospital capacity
increased the number of beds we have
53,000 we may need 110
we nee have 3000 ICU beds we may need
between eighteen to thirty seven
thousand that's my greatest concern
because that's where we need ventilators
to turn those ICU beds into beds for
people suffering from the virus we are
today issuing an emergency order that
says to all hospitals you must increase
your capacity by 50%
you must mandatory director from the
state find more beds use more rooms you
must increase your capacity 50% we would
ask you to try to increase your capacity
100% okay so we now have 53,000 beds we
need 110,000 beds if they increased the
capacity 100% that solves the
mathematical projection right
I think it's unreasonable to say to
every hospital basically double your
capacity I don't think it's unreasonable
to say try to reach a hundred percent
increase but you must reach a 50 percent
increase 50 percent increase were only
75,000 beds we still have a problem
between 75,000 and 110 once you've
secured the bed you have to secure the
staff you are going to have staff that
are getting sick and need to be replaced
you create these new beds you don't have
the staff for those new beds now they
just don't exist your staffing is - your
number of beds you increase the number
of beds you need more staff we are going
to the entire retired community health
care professionals and who are licensed
registered and we're saying we want you
to enlist to help it's not a mandatory
directive I can't legally but I probably
could legally ask them to come into
state service but this is just a request
we've put it out we've gotten very good
response
there are hundreds of thousands of
health care professionals who are
licensed to registered in this state but
we have 30,000 responses to date and I'm
doing an emergency order executive order
for all nurses who are registered to
enlist and the Department of Financial
Services is sending a directive to
insurance companies health insurance
companies employ many nurses doctors etc
in the insurance business we're saying
to the insurance companies we don't need
them in the insurance business now we
would like them to help in hospitals
because this is not about assessing
insurance claims at this point this is
about saving lives when we get to
assessing insurance claims we can handle
it then supplies are the ongoing
challenge nationwide masks PPE
ventilators are the number one precious
commodity this is happening on an ad-hoc
basis we are competing with other states
as I have said we have made certain
strides we have a full team working on
it we're very aggressive we're talking
to other countries around the world
we're talking to companies we have New
York manufacturers who are really
stepping up to the plate and converting
factories etc but this is not the way to
do it this is ad hoc I'm competing with
other states I'm bidding up other states
on the prices because you have
manufacturers who sit there and can't
California offers them for dollars and
they say well California offered $4 I
offer $5 another state calls in and/or
for $6 it's it's not the way to do it
I was speaking to a governor JB Pritzker
yesterday about this why are we
competing let the federal government put
in place the federal defense production
Act it does not nationalize any industry
all it does is say to a factory you must
produce the
quantity that's all it does I understand
the voluntary public/private sector
partnership and there are a lot of good
companies who are coming forward and
saying let us help but it can't just be
hey who wants to help let me know we
need to know what the numbers of what we
need produced and who is going to
produce that and when I get that a lot
of companies are stepping up and doing
good things and that's a beautiful thing
they're doing it here in New York too
but you can't run this operation that
way it can't just be based on we're
waiting for people to come forward with
offers and if you have to happen to get
a lot of offers on gloves then you have
a lot of gloves but if you get no offers
on masks then you don't have masks the
federal defense defense production Act
just says you can tell a company
manufacture this many by this date yes
it is an assertion of government power
on private sector companies yes but so
what this is a national emergency and
you're paying the private sector company
they're going to produce a good and
they're going to get paid and by the way
they're going to get paid handsomely you
cannot continue to do these supplies on
an ad-hoc basis we have had success
securing supplies we're going to be
dispatching them across the state today
these are the number of goods that are
going out you've heard on the news that
especially in New York City they're
worried about running out of supplies
again this won't get us through the
entire situation but this is a
significant amount of supplies that are
that will be going out New York City for
example four hundred and thirty thousand
surgical masks 176 thousand pairs of
gloves 72,000 gowns 90,000 face shields
169,000 n95 masks which are very
precious now
about $7 a mess so these are significant
supplies we have been having some
success in gathering them and we're
distributing them and this should make a
difference well it will make a
difference again not until the end of
the crisis but short term hospital
capacity I'm on my way down to the
Javits Center today I want to make sure
those hospitals are getting up right
away then we're gonna use Stony Brook
we're gonna use Westchester we're gonna
use Old Westbury president Trump did
deliver yesterday I put forth a series
of requests in the morning he did the
briefing in the afternoon and he
responded to those requests that's
government working that's government
working quickly and I thank him for it
it makes a big difference to New York
we're getting those emergency hospitals
the Javits hospitals for example those
are 1,000 beds right there with the
equipment with the ventilators and with
the staffing so that's a big deal
the president declared what's called a
met a major disaster declaration that
allows FEMA Federal Emergency Management
Agency to help us there's normally a 75
25 split between the cost of those
services federal government pays 75 the
state pays 25 I said to the president I
can't pay the 25 we just don't have
those kinds of resources the federal
government has the authority to waive
that 25 so the federal government pays
all 100 percent and that's what the
president is doing and I appreciate that
I also asked for the FDA to expedite the
approval of an experimental drug that we
are working on here in the state of New
York which I'll tell you more about in a
moment and the president also did that
the FDA gave the New York State
Department of Health approval to use on
a compassionate care basis a drug that
we think has real possibility
on the drug therapy Tuesday we're going
to start the hydroxychloroquine with the
zithromax that's the drug combination
that the president has been talking
about the FDA approved New York State
Department of Health to proceed with an
experimental drug again on a
compassionate care basis but what it
does is it takes the plasma from a
person who has been infected with the
virus processes the plasma and injects
the antibodies into a person who is sick
and there have been tests that show when
a person is injected with the antibodies
that then stimulates and promotes their
immune system against that disease it's
only a trial it's a trial for people who
are in serious condition but the New
York State Department of Health has been
working on this with some of New York's
best health care agencies and we think
it shows promise and we're going to be
starting that this week there's also
work on a cereal logical drug where you
test the antibodies of a person and see
if they had the virus already we all
believe thousands and thousands of
people have had the virus and self
resolved if you knew that you would know
who is now immune to the virus and who
you could send back to work etc so we're
also working on that the numbers today
total tested up to 78,000 tested
overnight 24-hour period 16,000 as of
yesterday about 25 percent of all the
testing nationwide is being produced
right here number of positive cases we
are up to 20,000 statewide 5,000 new
cases which is obviously a
significant increase and as I say that
trajectory is going up the wave is still
going up and we have a lot of work to do
to get that rate down and get the
hospital capacity up you see it
spreading across the state this way it's
spread across the nation and that will
continue my guess is every day we have
right now on hospitalizations 13% are
being hospitalized none of these numbers
are good but relatively that is a good
number
remembers the rate of hospitalizations
and the rate of people needing ICU beds
13% is down it does have gone as high as
20% 21% hovered around 18% 17% 13% is a
good number of that number
24% require the ICU beds the ICU beds
are very important because those are the
ventilators most impacted States you can
see that New York far and away has the
bulk of the problem and that's relevant
for the federal government that's
relevant for the congressional
delegation that is arguing for federal
funds fund the need fund the need New
York we have 20,000 cases New Jersey
1900 California 1800 so proportionately
in absolute terms New York has by far
the greatest need in the nation again to
keep this all in perspective Johns
Hopkins has studied every case from the
beginning three hundred forty nine
thousand cases death toll worldwide is
15 thousand right many will get infected
but few will actually pass away from
this disease
also this is all evolving and this is
all evolutionary and we are still
figuring it out there is there has to be
a balance or parallel tracks that we're
going down we're talking about public
health we're talking about isolation
we're talking about protecting
protecting lives there also has to be a
parallel track that talks about economic
viability I take total responsibility
for shutting off the economy in terms of
essential workers but we also have to
start to plan the pivot back to economic
functionality right you can't stop the
economy forever so we have to start to
think about does everyone stay out of
work should young people go back to work
sooner can we test for those who had the
virus resolved and are now immune and
can they start to go back to work
there's a theory of risk stratification
that dr. Katz who's at Yale University
is working on which is actually very
interesting to me which says isolate
people but really isolate the vulnerable
people don't isolate everyone because
some people most people are not
vulnerable to it and if you isolate all
people you may be actually exposing the
more vulnerable people by bringing in a
person who is healthier and stronger and
who may have been exposed to the virus
right can you get to a point where the
healthy the people who are most likely
not going to be affected can go to work
remember you study the numbers across
the countries that have been infected
the survival rate for those who
have been infected is like 98% right a
lot of people get it
very few people die from it so how do we
start to calculate that in we
implemented New York pause which stopped
all the essential workers etc we have to
start to think about New York forward
and Steve Cohen and Bill Monroe who I've
worked with for thirty years and now in
the private sector they're going to
start to think about this how do you
restart or transition to a restart of
the economy and how do you dovetail that
with a public health strategy as you're
identifying people who have had the
virus and have resolved can they start
to go back to work can younger people
start to go back to work because they're
much more tolerant to the effect of the
virus so how do you you turned off the
engine quickly how do you now start or
begin to restart or plan the restart of
that economic engine separate tasks but
something that we have to focus on I
offered my personal opinion yesterday I
separate my personal opinion from the
facts you can disregard my personal
opinion you can disregard facts but they
are still facts I said don't be reactive
be productive be proactive somebody few
people have said to me afterwards well
what what did that mean happens to me
often look this can go on for several
months okay nobody can tell you is a
four months six months eight months nine
months but it is several months we all
have to now confront that that is a new
reality that is not going to change
you're not going to turn on the news
tomorrow morning and they're going to
say surprise surprise this is all now
resolved in two weeks that is not going
to happen so deal with this reality
understand the negative effects of this
which I've spoken to personally because
these are personally negative effects
you don't feel them governmentally you
feel them personally you feel them in
your own life and don't underestimate
the emotional trauma and don't
underestimate the pain of isolation it
is real this is not the human condition
not to be comforted not to be close to
be afraid and you can't hug someone
Billy and and Steve walked in today I
hadn't seen them in months I can't shake
their hands I can't hug them you know
this is all unnatural my daughter came
up I'm I can't even really give her the
embrace and the kiss that I want to give
her this is all unnatural and
disorienting and it's not you it is
everyone it's it's the condition and we
are going to have time and the question
is how do we use this time positively
also at the same time we have to learn
from this experience because we were not
ready to deal with this and other
situations will happen other situations
will happen and let's at least learn
from this to be prepared for the next
situation as as dramatic as this one has
been also one of the finding the silver
lining the positive life is going to be
quieter for a matter of months
everything will function life will
function and everything will normal
operations there won't be chaos
the stores will have groceries gas
stations will have gasoline there's no
reason for extraordinary anxiety but it
is going to change you won't be at work
you can't be sitting in restaurants
you're not going to be going to birthday
parties you don't have to go to business
conferences on the weekends there's less
noise you know what that can be a good
thing in some ways you have more time
you have more flexibility you can do
some of those things that you haven't
done that you kept saying what I'd love
to be able to I'd love to be able to
well now you can
you have more time with family and yes I
get family in cramped quarters can be
difficult but it's also the most
precious commodity for myself
this young lady Kara is with me she
would never be here otherwise you know
I'm I'm bad right the last thing you
want to be when you're in Paris position
is hang out with the old man and hang
out with dad and hear bad dad jokes you
know they come for the holidays they'll
come when I give them heavy guilt but
I'm not going to be with Kara literally
for a few months what a beautiful gift
that is right I would have never had
that chance and that is precious and
then after this is over she's gone she's
flown the nest you know she's gonna go
do her thing but this crazy situation is
crazy as it is gave me this beautiful
gift
so one door closes another door opens
think about that and as I said normal
operations will continue as I've said
from day one the level of anxiety was
not connected to the facts there is no
chaos
the net effect many people will get the
virus but few will be truly endangered
hold both of those facts in your hands
many will get it up to 80% may get it
but few are truly endangered and we know
who they are realize the time frame that
we're expecting make peace with it and
find a way to help each other through
this situation because it's hard for
everyone and the goal for me socially
distanced but spiritually connected how
do you achieve socially distance but
spiritually connected I don't have the
answer but I know the question questions
comments
[Music]
well look you can the number of tests
will be a calibration at one point I
believe New York City's actions
Melissa knows better than I but I
believe in New York City's actions was
more on the availability of gowns and
equipment and that's a situation that
we're all struggling with we just are
going to send them a big shipment but I
can see local calibrations that
different localities are making or
hospitals are making on protocols within
their hospitals but we have to get down
that the bottom line remains we cannot
handle the wave at the high point the
wave has to come down and that is
density control and New York City give
me a plan especially for the parks and
young people and that is testing and
we're doing more than any place in the
country but testing isolation testing
isolation we haven't done the plan yet
as I said yesterday I wanted a plan in
24 hours I had a conversation with the
mayor I had a conversation with the City
Council Speaker Cory Johnson we talked
through a number of things I said put
her on a piece of paper because in truth
whatever I get from New York City I then
want to do in Westchester Nassau Suffolk
I don't want people saying in New York
City
well I'll just get in the car and go to
Westchester I'll get in the car or go to
Nassau that's why the geographic
template has been very important but I
haven't gotten it yet I we had a
conversation on parameters but I
actually want to plan a paper
oh yes oh yes this is all in addition
look I went there my density control
measures weren't enough that was clear
you could look at a park in Brooklyn
Manhattan it almost looked like any
Saturday any sunny Saturday you go
within need is Jimmy you follow the
science you follow the numbers you
listen to the data the majority of our
cases are coming out in New York City so
you go within need is you go where the
numbers are dr. Zook or do you want to
sure Thank You governor so the vast
majority of the ICU beds are down stays
proportional that most of the house a
lot of hospital beds are down this or
2/3 of those are are pretty much in the
city in the metropolitan area around the
city well yeah what we have now is we
have as the governor mentioned we have
about 600 individuals in the ICU but we
have many more ICU beds but we have does
the governor said prepare for the
potential for many more patients to come
in
one second I don't care upstate
downstate this is one state and we're
planning for one state if you get
overloaded in Albany then I'm going to
use the hospital beds in Utica
if I get overloaded in Buffalo I'm gonna
use the hospital beds in Rochester if I
get overloaded in New York City I'm
gonna use the hospital beds upstate
there is no upstate downstate here it's
one state I'm sorry
do you know that decipher the current
open capacity of ICU but I don't know
the exact number by having spoken to the
some of the hospital leadership members
there are beds and they are working to
create more ICU beds because you can
actually turn beds who that our recovery
room bed into an ICU bed and this is
what the the team that the government
asked the hospital associations to work
on and we'll have a report from them
shortly I haven't heard the specifics
about that but I know that we have
supplies available and as the governor
mentioned this slide that we are
providing them with more of the
protective equipment both masks as well
as gowns
Larry Schwartz has been handling the
supplies finding supplies with cemani to
sue both ik and they've been doing an
extraordinary job Cara's going to join
their team there is no one in this state
today who should be able to who can say
legitimately I can't get a mask if you
cannot get a mask we you saw the numbers
we're sending out we just were
successful in getting more and today we
can get masks to anyone who needs them
and gowns I can't promise you next week
or the week thereafter and that's why I
want to see the federal government do
this federal defense production Act and
stop this ad hoc volunteerism but today
there is no one who we can't cover
pardon the pun with the mask
measures to limit the spread of the
virus in state prisons jails we have
different policies that we put in place
all across the board
mirroring the nursing homes no visitors
same type of policies in prison
facilities and other facilities it's
something we're looking at yes look the
you have to walk and chew gum in life I
don't have the luxury no executive
really has the luxury of being
one-dimensional I'm very proud of the
measures we've taken to address this
public health crisis you look at our
numbers we've done things that no other
state in the country has done but I'm
also very aware that you cannot it is
unsustainable to run this state or run
this country with the economy closed
down right we're spending hundreds of
millions of dollars your people laid off
you have to get the economy up and
running so that has to be planned at the
same time and Steve Cohen and Bill
Monroe gonna do that there's another
complication which is what dr. Katz is
talking about can you have a public a
more refined public health strategy that
is also more productive or less
destructive to the economy could there
be a more intelligent public health
strategy that is more productive or less
destructive for the economy meaning is
it smart to Pokhara with me right
is it smart to have college kids coming
home kids staying home from school next
to their grandmother is that a smart
public health policy shouldn't you have
stratified the risk that's the public
health question and if you stratify the
risk can people start going back to work
and you start to restart that economy so
you're doing smart Public Health Policy
and smart economic policy I think there
is a line a dot with those two lines
cross you have to identify it and that's
what we're going to start to work
through no I have no I have no second
I have no second thoughts on actions
that I have taken I would make the same
decisions today I have no second thought
on going to zero
non-essential workers we sat here every
day
Jesse we saw that scale ticking up I
turned the valve a little bit I turned
the valve a little bit I turned the
valve a little made no difference I
turned the valve off by the way it still
hasn't brought the rate down low enough
so I have no second thoughts I'm sure
there will be political consequences I
know people are very angry about it I
had a gentleman tell me there's no way
we this state will ever reelect you
because of what you did frankly I don't
even care about that I did the right
thing and I'm proud of it at the same
time at one point you have to open the
valve right you have to open the valve
because that is oxygen for the economy
and this is not sustainable
doesn't appear in the two executive
orders issued over the weekend that
there were specific rules on canceling
all gather gatherings and large
gatherings you speak to if those rules
are a recommendation or do you plan on
putting those in writing in executive
order yeah I'm not sure what you're
referring to do you know what we know
it's a directive we put it out a couple
of days ago there's no gatherings of any
kind including weddings parties birthday
parties it's a directive across the
board if you're saying that there's some
confusion about that I'll ensure that
it's in an executive order today but
that was a directive it's not a
recommendation you can get married this
is just a very small it couldn't be
which is also very cost-effective it's
like the elopement it's a government
policy
she doesn't think whatever the
legislature is going to do their job
just like the executive is going to do
their job just which is our way of
honoring the heroes in public service
today the police officers are the
firefighters the nurses the health
workers the food delivery workers the
pharmacy workers all those people who
have to go out and do their job right so
the legislature would do their job the
executive will do their job we will pass
a budget and not just a budget we will
pass a budget and address the policy
items that we laid out and we discussed
because it's not just about passing a
budget in the numbers there are many
policy initiatives that I laid out back
in January and we're going to pursue all
of them the only caveat was if you have
a really complex issue that normally
would require weeks of nuanced detailed
negotiation to do it right that we won't
do because I don't want to pass any
bills that are not really intelligent
that I then have to come back and deal
with again next year
so if it's a highly complex issue I get
it and then let's put it off because we
don't want to do something sloppy but
otherwise no
bail Reform has to be done I want to do
legalizing marijuana
what does bail Reform look like I think
well you have different positions on
bail reform right you have the Assembly
of the Senate you have my proposal that
I did last year you have people that are
very concerned out there strong opinions
on both sides I just want to see a
resolution and progress and I want to
see it in the budget the there are
different things in there right
you have many costs in Medicaid that
have absolutely nothing to do with
anything we are doing now and you have
many parts of Medicaid that have grown
exponentially where frankly there is
gross waste gross waste and almost
periodically you have to go to any of
these government programs and you have
to question every premise every premise
why are we doing this why are we doing
this why are we doing this and you will
find there are ways to save money and
that's what we're doing here the we have
a I want to show you videos that the
state is running to help communicate to
New Yorkers they need to stay home they
need to isolate because we're trying to
get out the message I've been saying it
and everyone's been saying it but we
have to do a better job communicating so
we're trying a number of other vehicles
so just show them me Oh
I have to do everything myself hello
this is Robert DeNiro we all need to
stay home we need to stop the spread of
this virus and we can only do it
together not just to protect ourselves
but to protect others and all the older
people you love
please I'm watching you and I'm asking
you from the bottom of my heart all over
the state of New York
stay home I mean everybody I mean we got
this virus this pandemic and you know
young people can get it they can
transmit it to old people
next thing you know I matter so Governor
Cuomo asked me to ask you please do us a
favor all of us and stay home not spread
this virus around thank you
watch a little TV why don't ya one more
questions god yes about how the
infrastructure of New York City people
living on top of each other giant
apartment buildings Subway's how that
might just be contributing to the spread
of coronavirus then city controls bench
it density contributes to the spread of
the virus
airborne sneezing coughing and density
in that I touched this table the virus
could live here for two days you come
tomorrow I'm gone you touched that spot
in New York City or that density a lot
of people are touching or touching a lot
of spots right Park Bench grocery
counter you know just picture the city
and daily life and that's why in denser
areas you'll have a higher rate of
spread then a more suburban in more
rural communities it's just a function
of interaction
and proximity I have to go to the Javits
Center thank you very much guys
hospitalization number is from the
beginning I'm sorry just which third